what's going on guys summer movie season
whoo it's been a hot one we've had some
hits
we've had some misses and it got us
thinking what is the greatest summer
blockbuster of all time we have an
esteemed panel of brave hearty Souls
we're going to help us decide this
momentous question let's meet the panel
first oh it is a pleasure to have this
man he is an esteemed YouTube
personality is Doug Walker better known
as the nostalgia critic is McKenna Steve
you know from the schmoes know is that
you won he's also a very funny stand-up
comedian Mark Ellis his marriage was
performed by the rock Nick Mundy yeah
that's pretty good
here's how we determined what summer
movies are it had to come out between
May and Labor Day and it had to have
been the number one movie of the summer
we seeded them according to their
adjusted gross are you ready for this I
don't know if I can handle this mm-hmm
okay
oh this first matchup it's a barnburner
Star Wars versus Terminator 2 nostalgia
critic I gotta do Star Wars cuz it
changed everything Terminator 2 is
amazing but Star Wars is everything a
blockbuster should be Mark Ellis C 2 by
far for me is the best Terminator film
in the franchise I love Eddie furlong I
love Guns N'Roses I love Budnick from
salute your shorts the best answer is
easy and my Star Wars all right oh yeah
you tease me a little bit there Nick
what would you have said by the way do
it really yeah continuing our bracket of
best summer blockbuster ooh two of the
best superhero blockbusters of all time
the number nine see Dark Knight against
the number eight seed The Avengers
hmm we're gonna start with Mark Ellis on
this one I love the Dark Knight but I
think for a summer blockbuster film the
best comic book movie of all time
would be the Avengers boys I'm going to
ventures prove me wrong one Oh Avengers
Nick Mundy deal with it Internet The
Avengers Wow
I don't have to
for me wrong y'all gonna agree to the
adventure oh I like dark night better
but you're right it's just a more
traditional summer blockbuster don't
look now but Batman is going to have a
chance for a revenge because it is the
Empire Strikes Back versus the number 13
seed Batman 89 Tim Burton Batman here's
the thing Empire is a great movie but
Batman has a prince song and he was
think Batman was the first summer movie
I remember so I'm going Batman you are
hoping that Batman bat dances into the
second round you know we already have
the Star Wars uh and Empire's more of a
thinking Star Wars film where Batman's
more like it's it's a little thinking
but it's a summer blockbuster it's
Batman it's super hero you gotta go
abandon Batman moving on what's
happening The Empire Strikes Back losses
it would be first round it would be
better with more Batman you guys are
just giving it to Batman because his
other movie and get in and we already
got a star one star in there yeah so
smart enough print singing which movie
has Yoda and boba things are not even
through the first round and all hell has
broken loose I call this the jeff
goldblum smackdown number 12
Independence Day vs. number 5 the one
that started it all Jurassic Park
traffic park hands down Jurassic Park
what no mark I was so excited to get my
answer as Independence Day because it is
the most one of the most fun
blockbusters I've ever seen Jurassic
park's a great movie the 12/5 matchup
you always get an upset I think it's
here I can't wait we are all tied up
decide it Monday this is why I picked
independent by the way this
consternation right here come on you got
Judd Hirsch versus Dennis Nedry Bill
Paxton versus Bill Pullman versus Santa
Sabina creating Jurassic world of
eldress Park Jurassic Park moving on the
first round continues oh this breaks my
heart this matchup number two seed et
versus number 15 seed Toy Story 3 Mark
Ellis we have our first George Mason I'm
calling the upset the 15 seed is
toppling number 2 Toy Story 3
be eating Wow Nik Mundi be good look
look look
PT Haiti because more kids need to watch
ET they probably all seen Toy Story 3
honors lots of new stuff nostalgia
critic
even though I like Toy Story 3 better in
his summer blockbuster it is eating eg
moving on Nick Monday we're gonna start
with you I know you're gonna choose here
number 10 see ghostbusters against
number 7 seed Forrest Gump goes off ok
do we need to what Oh
ghostbusters ghostbusters pardon me
while I paraphrase lose Forrest lose
this one I thought it's driving me nuts
number three Jaws against number 14 seed
Back to the Future nostalgia critic look
jaws agassi back to the future Mark
Ellis jaws first Back to the Future
summer blockbuster which do you pick I
love both of these movies when I think
summer blockbuster I first think fun but
jaws is the reason why we had any of
these other movies to talk about it was
the first summer blockbuster I'm giving
it to Bruce the shark from Jaws
back in futures all-time all-time
classic Mac the futures my jaws it's
what made me love movies it's back to
the future what jaws doesn't have a Huey
Lewis song to me biggest shocker of the
first round oh I called over there have
a cold
ok ok the final match for the first
round the number 11 seed Raiders of the
Lost Ark against the number six seed Sam
Raimi's first spider-man Sam Raimi
spider-man is a tremendous
accomplishment it helped get comic book
movies back to the forefront but Raiders
of the Lost Ark is an adventure cereal
like no other one of those fun films of
all time that's what I'm taking this is
easy
Raiders boom Raiders of the Lost Ark
moving on epic smackdowns
that's all we have right now Star Wars
versus the Avengers Nick Mundy Wow josma
is started um actually the action summer
blockbuster but Star Wars is with
created fandom for better or worse so
I'm going to have to go in this regard
with Star Wars
and yes I do mean that Terminator 2 is
better than both of them nostalgia
critic Star Wars versus the Avengers you
know I get a feeling we're gonna watch
Avengers years later we're still really
gonna like it but we're gonna do some
things are kind of dated or whatever
we're with Star Wars that film is years
and years old it's just a timeless story
and it's never gonna date so yeah I
gotta go Star Wars Star Wars moving on
all right everybody on Alderaan you
didn't die for nothing Star Wars made it
okay this round continues Batman 89 vs.
Jurassic Park nostalgia critic Ben is
one of my favorite movies like top 10
all-time favorite movies but summer
blockbuster Jurassic park's just going
to hit more people it's dinosaurs kids
can watch it those can watch it everyone
can like it it's gotta be transferred
Mark Ellis yeah I saw Jurassic Park like
five times that summer and I was in a
movie theater I don't think I've seen a
movie that much since then but Batman
1989 was the first blockbuster I saw in
a movie theater I think that it
revitalized what a blockbuster could be
in the summertime plus it introduced me
to movie theater nachos so I'm here at
the Batman we are all tied up 1-1 Batman
versus Jurassic Park Nick Monday dropped
the hammer
oh man so like here because you know and
then of course thank you that cleared up
a lot better
hey hey Nick I don't judge you say it
you say yeah yeah you're right cuz
here's the thing as much as I love
Batman and as much as I love Prince
Jurassic Park still holds up where it
could compete with any movie of the day
effect story it's just I'm gonna go
Jurassic Park over Batman and I'm
apologizing to Michael Keaton right now
Jurassic era moving on to the
semi-finals
alright um it doesn't get any easier
folks we've got et versus ghostbusters
this is good easy Mark Ellis look I like
et I don't feel like there to think I
hate et you're gonna get back at ghost
bus and say it's not only one of the
best blog about you boys 100 you know
it's gonna be just it goes but super
quick Elijah do it do it Ghostbuster
Monday Ghostbuster all right
the oh this is a toffee no there's a
mecca for Spielberg back to the future
versus Raiders of the Lost Ark Mundi
back to the future back to the future is
one of the most perfect move on oh no
it's come back the effects hold up the
acting is great it's one of the like Doc
Brown is revolutionary Marty McFly's the
best Crispin Glover shoulda won an
Academy Award
performances are wonderful it goes up
more than Raiders of the ls arc it's the
perfect movie back to the future vs
Raiders of the Lost Ark there's a lost
art okay it's just amazing there's a
board it's sci-fi action B movie it's
the where's the Lost Ark it's baby's
future turns awesome yeah the future
interview guys had the job I have which
is choosing between my two children who
are correct ooh
this choice I do not envy you idiot
judge raised an oscar raiders of the
water dark your charlatan ladies and
gentlemen our final four is set I'll go
back in time and fire your dad's Star
Wars Jurassic Park ghostbusters Raiders
of the Lost Ark Spielberg hanging strong
with two flicks in here as he should
Star Wars vs. Jurassic Park sir again
just back to the timeless argument Star
Wars is still more timeless we got one
Oh Star Wars / Jurassic Park Mark Ellis
well we got the prequels and the only
reason we had the prequels this because
Jurassic Park revolutionized computer
effects but you wouldn't have Jurassic
Park unless you had Star Wars of New
Hope in 1977 Star Wars is the champion
versus the dinosaurs they're great but
they can't use the Force I don't know if
I followed your logic but I got your
vote
Star Wars moving on / Jurassic Park
ghostbusters vs. Raiders of the Lost Ark
Wow my logic dictates that I like back
to the future maybe a little bit better
than Ghostbusters and so if I gave very
doesn't lost like the edge over Back to
the Future I by law have to give Raiders
of the Lost Ark the edge the answer is
Raiders of the Lost Ark we're talking
summer blockbusters Monday let me remind
you all we're talking summer
movie yeah and I'm sorry but when I
think of summer I think of Bill Murray
smoking a signal to ghosts
okay I think about winston zeddemore
just try to get a job I got that hang on
I'm talking about
Ray Ray much Slimer left Gozer who gave
me a weird boner when i watched it at
the appropriate age I'm talking about
ghostbusters
I mean and ghost buzz it feels good will
it even get out of this round
it should nostalgia I read it good if it
goes much it's gotta be ghostbusters cuz
Natalie doesn't have the great action
not only does it have the great
performances not only is it an entirely
different kind of summer blockbuster but
it's funny yeah and bring us a Lost Ark
as funny stuff too but Ghostbusters is a
comedy and it's an action film as well
and as dark stuff as bracelet when you
go in you I have just a blast watching a
movie that's one of the first things
that comes to my head - it's
ghostbusters ghostbusters in the vinyl
here it is can you see my chicken
scratch it's insane we've arrived to our
final two Ghostbusters vs. Star Wars
all right gentlemen are you ready for
this good up first
Nick Mundy next I just write down
Ghostbusters for you yeah well I love
small word yes Ghostbuster Devine get
out I love Star walk yes you can stay
with the war is that the anyone I like
it's not war that's about it yeah Mark
Ellis what do you got ladies and
gentlemen of the internet stars this
feels good star was not only kicked off
the action sci-fi huge summer
blockbuster which Ghostbusters had a lot
of elements in it Ghostbusters is very
funny and I love Bill Murray and Slimer
and all the ghosts but this is the
prototypical summer blockbuster Star
Wars is the thing that we all celebrate
that some people subscribe to as a
religion Jedi Knights are more than just
a summer movie but they are also the
greatest summer blockbuster of all time
the answer is Star Wars Wow grew up it's
one one Ghostbusters versus Star Wars it
all comes down to you nostalgia critic
you know the right answer just say I do
know the right answer as much as I love
the other terms of the most fun
Ghostbusters oh my god yeah Oh
feel good ladies and gentlemen boys and
girls that started out as the number 10
seed and it is now the number one summer
blockbuster Ghostbusters yes no time
liner I'm gonna smoke a cig like Eggman
and then go hang out any pot don't smoke
kids what is your favorite summer
blockbuster of all time what did you
think of their picks tell us in the
comments section below
coolest answer we're gonna send you a
screen junkies t-shirt I want to thank
my esteemed banner Doug Walker the
Nostalgia Critic thank you for being
here safe random Marc Ellis you're still
the cute one NIC Mundy congratulations
on Ghostbusters I want to thank you for
watching I'm how red neck hit us all up
on Twitter bye-bye listen makes me feel
you Timecop is beating the matron
Timecop is a better movie than the
matrix not just because of the splits on
the countertop film and dams bosses
d-day from Animal House this is
unprecedented the 16 seed Timecop
knocking off the one seed the matrix